plus tôt dans la lutte contre les
épidémies on ne prendrait aucun risque
sur rien c'est à dire qu'on ne ferait
plus rien et donc moi je d'ailleurs je
suis farouchement pour la suppression de
ce principe de précaution dans la
constitution et le remplacer par un
principe de prudence qui est pas du tout
pareil alors qu'un couple qui n'a pas
été sans doute prudent ce sont isabelle
et patrick balkany
hier ils ont écopé de trois ans de
prison ferme plus un an de sursis pour
l'ancien maire en première instance
certains s'étaient émus vous souvenez
d'une peine que ces projets est
exagérément lourdes notamment avec ce
mandat de dépôt à la sortie de
l'audience
et cette fois sur les réseaux d'aucuns
s'étonnent tout au contraire devoir
sortir le couple libre du tribunal alors
la condamnation at-elle été sévère selon
vous on écoute
isabelle balkany sur ce sujet vous savez
je trouve qu'il ya une certaine
indécence c'est pas du tout dans mon
tempérament de parler de la santé les
uns et les autres a surtout de mon mari
mais là il ya une certaine indécence à
le faire mais je suis obligé de le faire
parce que il a fallu que j'ai cette
indécence que j'assume cette indécence
pour que au bout de cinq ans et demi
une expertise médicale judiciaire soit
demandé alors que nous la demandions
depuis le début alors ça c'était le 13
février dernier c'est évidemment la vie
d'isabelle de 4 ans balkany elle seule
c'était le 13 février lors du conseil
municipal et au lendemain de la sortie
de prison de son époux leurs intérêts de
bezina qu'est ce que vous en penser
objectivement c'est sévère ou pas je
m'adresse à la juriste évidemment bien
sûr ces douleurs objectivement je pense
là là là la question de l'application de
la législation elle est là bon
on a un délit de fraude fiscale a gravé
en tous sens possibles et imaginables
sophistiqués voilà un et c'est vrai que
yahia de la fraude aggravée il ya de la
fraude sur des années il ya de la
manipulation des textes donc on est
vraiment dans dans l'exemple type j'ai
envie de dire presque théorique à
l'intention de jusqu'à 4 millions
d'euros voilà qui mérite sanction
évidemment la question de la
proportionnalité de la sanction elle est
compliquée pour les délits dits de cols
blancs qui sont en réalité la catégorie
du droit pénal financier parce que
justement on a toujours ce sentiment que
ce ne sont pas des bandits de grand
chemin et que donc les mettre en prison
ne correspond pas exactement à leurs
fautes et c'est pour ça que généralement
le droit tape plutôt là où ça fait mal
sur ce type de délit en ayant des sommes
astronomiques d'amande qui sont
infligées
ici c'est vrai que c'est l'une des
premières fois je rappelle ça n'est
quand même pas la première fois que on
ressort de ce type d'infraction de cols
blancs avec des de la pénalisation mais
là aussi ça n'est pas la faute du juge
les lois de 2013 2015 et 2017 sur la
transparence la moralisation matière
économique et financière n'ont fait que
durcir les sanctions
donc on ne peut pas ensuite en vouloir
aux juges d'appliquer les lois qu'on a
voulu durcir sans arrêt est ce que ce
n'est pas aussi un changement de
doctrine du parc et financière c'est un
changement de doctrine du parquet
financier faut savoir que c'est
peut-être aussi un petit peu pour cela
qu'il a été créé puisqu'il résulte d'une
loi de la ville on rêve sur la
transparence financière et justement qui
est la même à avoir alourdi les
pénalités en matière de fraude sur la
jonction avec l'inéligibilité moi je
crois qu'elle est quand même
relativement saine là aussi dans dans
ces législations 2013 15 et 17
ce qu'on essaye de nous dire c'est que
pour être aux manettes politique
mieux vaut quand même balayé devant sa
porte d'abord on a quand même tout sans
même en mémoire l'exemple de jérôme
cahuzac qui vient de venir
le chantre de la fraude et qui lui-même
en écoute pas donc il y a deux ans la
rente et jérôme cahuzac avait pris deux
ans ce qui veut dire c'est une peine
aménageable et que lui a pu bénéficier
d'un break tronic et pas de prison deux
ans et pas de prison en f1 c'était deux
ans ferme voilà aménager un bracelet
électronique ce qui est évidemment
vraiment ce qui touche le plus ce qui
est le plus fort c'est la prison
l'inégibilité temps très importantes
mais ceux qui frappent l'opinion s'est
malgré tout la prison sachant que
justement là on est en train de
reprocher au juge ne pas en avoir donné
puisque c'est la prison avec sursis ici
donc voila moi j'en dis dès qu'il ya
beaucoup de paradoxes dans ce qu'on
reproche aux décisions de justice les
décisions de justice sont les décisions
justice moi je crois que c'est important
que des fois on remette un petit peu
l'église au milieu du village et ce type
d'arrêt est un art et d'exemplarité la
seule réserve que j'ai et que je crois
qu'il faut quand même posé sur la table
c'est celle du temps on a beaucoup de
balance beaucoup de choses à leur
balance les balkany balance le cinéma
balance le sport on sait très bien qu'on
libère la parole
mais la seule limite c'est celle du
temps c'est à dire que finalement les
époux balkany sont sanctionnés
maintenant alors que les fraudes pour
certaines datent des années 90 ce qu il
ya eu ce changement de la mentalité qui
a amené à ce changement de la
législation qui amène à ce changement
mais le même temps de jeu mais cher le
passé peut-être que voilà le principe
normalement c'est que la loi nouvelle
s'applique à l'avenir bon ici ils ont
été recherchées maintenant mais laissons
un peu de temps à l'abaissement aussi je
crois que c'est important
alors je suis parmi nos internautes ce
sujet le passionne également et
notamment je relève ce commentaire il ya
des criminels tueur et terroristes à
mettre derrière les barreaux bien
heureux assure renault sur régal figaro
live est ce que c'est un peu trop
provocateur ça qu'est ce que vous en
pensez
mathieu broquet moi je vais plutôt vous
plutôt rejoindre une semaine c'est que
après tout ils sont élus de la
république
ils ont quand même un devoir on parle d'
exemplarité de la peine moi j'aimerais
bien qu'on parle d' exemplarité des élus
voilà je trouve ça bien que on ait une
justice aussi libre et indépendante qui
malgré des élus balkany qui sont adorés
à levallois perret qui ont été quand
même réélu malgré toutes les accusations
qui portait déjà sur eux et qu'ils sont
vraiment adoré sur place malgré la
proximité de patrick balkany avec
notamment un ancien président et donc
avec certains
je dirais de pouvoir et est placé en
détention
non justement je trouve que c'est plutôt
un taiseux c'est plutôt une belle
réussite de notre justice libre et
indépendante de montrer que la fraude
fiscale la peine je crois pour la fraude
fiscale vous m'arrêtez si jean baptiste
mais c'était ça jusqu'à cinq ans et cinq
cent mille euros d'amande ou le double
des sommes sur lesquelles ils se sont
fait de l'argent je crois que c'est à
peu près ça bon 3 en sachant que c'est
un détournement aggravé sophistiqué
enfin quand même plein de mots de qui
nous sont rapportées de ce2 ce2 ce
procès qui disent que ils ont quand même
bien bien charger la mule on va dire sur
ça ça me paraît pas complètement fou
d'autant que vu leur état de santé ce
qui est très probable est ce que je
souhaite aussi effectivement ça n'a pas
grand intérêt d'aller mettre monsieur
patrick balkany mais la mise à la base
il faut alors c'est plus une question de
principe c'est une question de principe
c'est bien qu'ils aient été condamné
fermement dix ans d'inéligibilité pour
des personnes qui sont des élus de la
république et ceux qui sont censés être
exemplaire oui c'est une bonne chose
alors certains que ça permet aussi de
mettre en exergue tous ces maires on est
en pleine période des municipales ça
permet aussi de mettre en exergue tous
les maires qui font très très très bien
mais ça ne s'est pas encore
l'affrontement entre le politique et le
judiciaire l'enjeu qui ça va me dire ce
que vous en pensez vous moi je vis très
largement d'accord avec ce qui a été dit
je voudrais quand même un petit bémol
quand même la personnalisation des
peines est aussi un principe fondamental
semble dans cette affaire à le voir
jouer contre eux les justiciables
puisque compte tenu de son âge déjà à
l'horizon 60 oui et 11 ans vont lui et
60 à la raison pour l jeu mais peu de
gens au dessus 70 ans en prison en
france pour toutes sortes de raisons il
y en a peu et je crois que c'est quand
même je parle je crois que c'est sans
précédent pour une affaire comme ça
d'autant que encore une fois jérôme
cahuzac proche regarder le dossier
cahuzac s'était quand même pas du léger
1 avec mensonges devant la
représentation nationale avec plusieurs
affaires pas une seule
jérôme cahuzac s'est ces deux ans
étaient ces cinq ans il est quand même
beaucoup plus jeunes ces cinq ans
d'inéligibilité je suis tout à fait
d'accord un champ qu'il faut taper à
fond sur dîner mais pourquoi cinq ans
seulement dans ce cas là là les les
balkany hausse et qu'ils ne seront plus
jamais oui tandis que cahuzac bon cinq
ans la question qui se pose est que moi
que je me pose tout de même c'est que
tout cela grains de nature sous le même
régime des mêmes lois à créer
l'impression qu' il ya une insécurité
juridique c'est-à-dire qu'on ne sait pas
très bien à quelle sauce on va être
mangé ou est ce que je veux dire
est-ce qu'on va la faire de la prison
pas de prison selon quels critères
qu'ils décidèrent plus dans la prison la
sécurité non mais ce que dire par là
c'est que la sécurité juridique elle est
sûre c'est fondamental dans un état de
droit c'est à dire qu'on se dit quel que
soit le procureur qu'elle ce qu'elle
soit le juge
ça va être plus tôt voilà l'un d'eux
fenêtre voilà là je trouve qu'il ya une
différence de traitement qui est quand
même je met pas du tout en cause qu'elle
les attentions mais je trouve qu'elle
pose quand même question encore une fois
sur le traitement distinct de deux
justiciables mais je terminerai par une
compliments à madame balkany qui dans
toute cette affaire a été d'un génie
rhétorique extraordinaire car ce qu'elle
vient de dire est fabuleux sur son
indécence et alès
c'est qui est une magnifique anti
logique comme on dit en rhétorique et
elle a su admirablement jouée sur le
bateau sur mon âme est malade 1 et je
laime et et ça je trouve que l a
admirablement jean louis et habile parce
qu'au contraire la défense a été très
décriée ah oui mais tout à période entre
la prison et la libération elle a été
excellent label balkany a été
exceptionnelle pour jouer sur l'opinion
publique et remettre une pression quand
même en faveur de la libération de son
mari
ce à quoi elle est parvenue je ne crois
quand même pas qu'on peut parler de
justice à deux vitesses et je crois
qu'il faut qu'on fasse attention avec ce
genre de mots non je dis insécurité
juridique et vous avez parlé
d'individualisation de la peine deux
minutes avant et comment voulez vous
qu'on applique à la sphère cahuzac le
raisonnement qu'on a appliqué à la
sphère malkani sont deux affaires très
différent des dents les déficits rome
est en mis en avant cette histoire
d'exemplarité on a dit voilà c'est vrai
qu'ils votent la loi de votre courant de
la fraude fiscale dans les deux cas il
ya bien plus quand même chez les balkany
déjà en terme de ce sommet en termes de
cumul d'infractions et c'est vraiment là
dessus que la peine a été difficile et
lourde mais on peut pas reprocher ça à
une juridiction je suis désolé notamment
sur la fraude c'est la seule c'est l'une
des seules infractions qui peut être à
la fois pénale fiscales sociales et qui
peut donc aller devant différentes
juridictions et la fraude des balkany
est une fraude
fiscal une fraude à la déclaration une
fraude au paiement ça a été une fraude
sur la tva il ya vraiment c'est un
manuel de droit public financier collet
que les eagles à faire vous avez vous
avez fraude fiscale comptes à l'étranger
de non déclaration de patrimoine
c'est vrai je crois pas que
l'exemplarité de l'un ne soit pas
l'exemplarité de l'une et de l'autre je
pense justement que sur ces deux
affaires on a eu des sanctions qui ont
été relativement lourd parce que ce sont
des élus de la république et je crois
qu'au contraire on a pris en compte le
fait que les époux balkany sont âgés et
je crois que vous avez tout à fait
raison de dire que la première peine
quand il s'agit de le mettre
physiquement en prison était sûrement un
peu excessive
aujourd'hui la décision qui est rendue
en appel a justement bonne arsenault
alors voilà on est là à nouveau un
consensus marie visot est ce que cette
question d'exemplarité pour vous et je
parlais pas vraiment de la première est
d'accord est-ce que alors vous voulez
vous les mettez en prison l'intelligence
donc moi je vais dire que je ne alors
non je pense qu'il faut bien plus à moi
je ne suis absolument pas juriste mais
faut bien plus joué sur l'inégibilité de
ces gens pour qui c'est toute la vie la
politique la vie la vie publique c'est
toute leur vision là on est riche et
l'argent public en plus on les prive de
ça on les prive de tout mois après je ne
l'aimé pas prêt je n'excuse pas ce
qu'ils ont fait mais je n'aimais pas en
prison les prisons sont pleines
accessoires accessoirement ils sont pas
en bonne santé il faut les mettre dans
des quartiers vip ça coûte une fortune
bref si aucun intérêt à les mettre en
place voilà alors ça c'était l'avis
financier de la question c'est très dur
c'est très jeremy bentham
jérémy est vrai c'est très utilitariste
on reconnaît l'économiste
on a reconnu l'économiste les juristes
et 4 merci voilà pour cette belle
rhétorique merci et à demain même heure
même punition point de vue présentée par
charlotte darche